c'est demain un corps a lieu comme
chaque année la journée mondiale de
l'alimentation malgré le décollage des
pays émergents on estime que cinq
millions d'enfants malnutris meurent
chaque année essentiellement en afrique
et c'est dans ce contexte que
l'association médecins sans frontières
lance un appel à une révolution elle
souhaite que l'aide humanitaire soit
réorientée vers ce qu'on appelle les
aliments thérapeutiques alors de quoi
s'agit-il
et bien de cette pâte mise au point il y
a une dizaine d'années elle se présente
ainsi en sachets ou en petits pots ça
sent un peu l'arachide
elle est prête à l'emploi facilement
stockables et conservable et possède des
qualités nutritives qu'on dit
exceptionnel alors miracle ou mirage
les avis sont partagés voici les
arguments des uns et des autres c'est le
débat du jour avec renaud bernard et
mathieu dreujou cette pâte au bout de
cacahuètes atouts du remède miracle là
où elle est distribuée les enfants ne
meurent plus de faim
huile sucre arachides et sels minéraux
un concentré d'aliments essentiel à la
survie chaque os pèse 100 g
un repas complet de 500 kcal le taux de
guérison en cas de malnutrition aiguë et
de 95%
pourtant sur 854 millions de victimes de
la faim dans le monde
seuls six cent mille enfants ont
aujourd'hui accès à cette pâte
révolutionnaire à droite médecins sans
frontières accuse le manque de volonté
de la communauté internationale à gauche
l'onu répond que la pâte coûte trop cher
alors question peut-on la généraliser à
tous les enfants qui ont faim de 24
milliards de dollars 24 milliards de
dollars
c'est aujourd'hui huit fois le budget
annuel du pam
c'est tout à fait possible il ya eu
d'autres actions du même ans quand on a
voulu
élargir l'accès aux
aux vaccins de base dans le monde qu'on
a lancé au début des années 80 les
programme élargi de vaccination
on a fait des filières de production de
vaccins a pris sous flux souvent sonné
ce qui a permis de travailler avec des
vaccins 20 x 30 fois moins cher que le
prix du marché
mais pour combattre la famine il faut
aussi s'attaquer à ses racines quand les
cours mondiaux des produits agricoles
sont en chute libre
les paysans des pays pauvres vendent à
perte ruinés ils n'ont alors plus les
moyens de se protéger de la fin
aujourd'hui les femmes insee plus
seulement le climat ou les criquets
c'est aussi les lois du marché et ses
lois du marché font que par exemple dans
des crises comme celle du niger il ya
deux ans eh bien les populations de
petits paysans pouvait avoir accès à une
nourriture mais avait pu les moyens
d'accéder à la nourriture
pourtant la faim n'est pas un fléau
insurmontable dans les années 80 avec la
famine en ethiopie la mobilisation
internationale a fait reculer le nombre
de victimes de 1 milliard à 790 millions
en dix ans avant que la courbe repartent
à la hausse
comme si soudainement la question avait
cessé d'être préoccupante